sticking with us is dave rubin host of
the political talk show the rubin report
on youtube we've talked trump we've
talked classical liberalism we've talked
about so many different things
okay so Dave I sat through what felt
like a very enjoyable endless hours of
Rubin report and there's a couple very
specific things I want to touch on
because I feel like they might be
attacks on me personally not not
directly but de facto you said in an NAU
you said innocent in an interview with
Ben Shapiro that liberalism is basically
a mental disorder what did you mean by
that I don't think I said liberalism I
might have said progressivism or maybe
you said the left is basically a mental
disorder that I think the idea was
progressivism the left left ISM whatever
the case may be it's basically a man hey
disorder for the record if I said
liberalism then it was an absolute brain
freeze but I'm 99% sure I didn't say
that it may end before if they have been
before you started where before you
shifted language on it it was a little
bit a little bit ago yeah I don't think
so though but anyway I'm sure that some
of the internet salutes around here
we'll find it I'm pretty sure I said
progressive okay um well first off it it
had nothing to do with you you know no I
know if there be cursin allah but i am
curious like what about progressive
ideology strikes you as being a mental
disorder okay so first off i said it in
a glib way - i think it's an actual
mental disorder no I don't think it's a
mental disorder that should be studied
and I would like to study a couple of
these progressives but I would study
some conservatives - and one you know
you could probably figure out that their
brains are wired a little differently
okay fine so putting that aside the big
I was being glib obviously but the the
point that I'm trying to make is that
the I sort of what I just said you in
the previous segment if your issues are
the gut think about all the proof I mean
while I was on T YT three years
everything's about the government's
horrible everyone's corrupt everyone's
evil corporations money is destroying
everything billionaires bah-bah-bah
what's your answer make the government
bigger tax people more force the
government to do more below that seems
antithetical to logic and reason
so I so yes it is not a mental disorder
but I think basically if you could get a
group of progressives to sit down and
not scream at you that you're a bigot
and a racist and a homophobe which by
the way I'm sure that there are people
that flirt use those slurs on you even
though you are of the left and consider
yourself a progressive I think if you
could get some people to sit down and
really talk about ideas and these
principles on this philosophic
underpinnings of the things that we're
talking about I think you could get
people to understand that if your
problem is the corruption your the
problem is the money and all those
things then stop making the problem
bigger that this isn't about what the
founding fathers intended they intended
a very weak federal government and local
control and local power and state power
and I'm for all of those things so yes
the comment was done glibly but I assure
you it had nothing to do with date
attack well I think that this is where
you know we sort of get to what I think
is my my core disagreement with you
aside from like really specific policy
things like it seems like we're sort of
in a different place on tax policy for
example we probably don't agree exactly
on what the size of the government
should be but you and I have talked
privately about our concerns with the
sort of a speech policing trigger
warning safe space stuff we both talked
about that we've expressed concern about
some knee-jerk positions that don't seem
fact based on the israeli-palestinian
conflict etc I think it's a matter of
degree that I think you believe that
those issues are much bigger among the
left than I perceive them to be and I've
talked about the college campus stuff
that's going on but I still think it's
limited to a particular type of mostly
you know liberal arts colleges I don't
think it's the major issue that some of
your guests make it out to be are we
sort of having a disagreement too on the
degree to which these issues are a
problem yeah so I would say that's a
fair place to have a disagreement which
by the way I love having a disagreement
at man you know I like you I consider
you a friend do you we're going to do my
show if you were going to be in LA last
week it didn't work but we'll get my in
here the whole
point of this experiment as I described
it before of America is that we're
supposed to disagree on these things
we're supposed to disagree and be able
to walk away and realize that we want to
live in the same Society because I don't
want to kill you for your beliefs and
hopefully you don't want to kill me for
mine so as for the the free speech stuff
no I I don't think that I'm overstating
it or that my guests are overstating it
this this idea of the trigger warnings
of the safe spaces of the speech police
of deep platforming Richard Dawkins at
Berkeley which is happening on August
7th he's bendy platform I'm happy I'm
actually interviewing him in New York at
the 92nd Street Y on August 8th they
haven't stopped us yet but I'm sure
there will be people that aren't happy
that we're doing that this kind of
insanity stopping Jordan Peterson from
speaking being I'm sure I don't have to
tell you about what happened with brett
weinstein up at Evergreen State
so evergreens a great example by the way
because this is supposed to be the most
left but you could argue that this is
the most left college in America well
certainly in the top ten so you would
think that they would have all this
harmony that these ideas of non racism
and plurality and all of this stuff and
multiculturalism would have worked but
the students there would have you
believe that this is some sort of insane
racist crazy place Brent Weinstein was
fighting racism he was fighting
segregation now I get that and I
defended him I mean I got a call about
it a couple weeks ago and I defended him
and you know a lot of my family is is
college professors and I've got an
announcement to make about a college
involvement that I'm going to be having
and from my from from everything I'm
looking at there are these several dozen
examples that you cite but the ideas
that the left at large has been taken
over by this it's like I went to the
women's March rallies here in Boston and
there was about 10% stuff that I thought
was totally unproductive and a shutdown
of attempts for open debate and it was
bad and I'm against it but I'm just not
on board that it's a problem to the
degree that you think it is and I think
it's really easy to look at these
isolated incidents and believe that it
represents everybody on the left but I'm
just not seeing it well first off I've
never said it represents everybody
unless it represents what the mainstream
Left has become without question now we
can just disagree on the percentage
there and that
gine but these look we know that by
they've done a zillion Studies on it I
don't want to quote the number wrong but
that's something like 80 or 90% of
professors in America are liberal to
left now it depends what you mean by
liberal of course in that case but we
know that the conservative viewpoint is
not being taught in in colleges and by
the way it's leaking into not just the
humanities it's actually leaking into
the science stuff and I was at a
conference with about 400 college
professors in Dallas a couple weeks ago
and many people were talking about that
so I've talked to tons of professors
about this I would recommend if you can
get Jonathan Haidt on your show I think
he's doing the best work on this and
runs something called a heterodox
Academy which is about getting more
diversity of thought at college campuses
but when I go to college campuses I get
kids from every walk of life and every
color and sexuality and all that stuff
all that diversity that the less loved I
care about diversity of thought more but
I get kids saying that they their
teachers are telling them to use certain
gender pronouns they say well I'm not
against trans people but if I see
someone they happen to look like a man
I'm going to say he or him and I'm not
trying to offend anybody and if I may
want them to use E or Zed or whatever
the hell it is that these ideas these
ideas which are taking root in the left
this strange alliance with Islam all of
this stuff that shaking rooting left is
not being countered by anyone on the
left actually
anytime someone on the Left tries to
counter it they're kicked out and and I
think you can probably speak to that
yourself and serve listen I mean I get
criticized no there's no doubt I I mean
I'm on the left and I counter it I've
not yet been kicked out of any place
none of my college speaking events that
are planned for the fall have been
canceled so far I mean if it happens
I'll absolutely tell you as well as my
audience you know yeah well I I don't
know what your specific criticisms have
been that they would that what they
would lead you to lead them to kicking
you out yeah but as a general rule as a
general rule there is no question in my
mind that that people that are thought
of as traditionally right at the moment
are being more tolerant of other ideas
than people of the left it's just I see
this in every walk of life I also fear
that the big
problem we have right now is that the
ideas of the left of a bigger state of
taking more of the collected versus the
individual I would recommend your
audience watch my either in my
interviews with ayaan Hirsi Ali who does
a wonderful explanation of the
individual and why we have to care about
individual rights as opposed to
collective right yeah um I these ideas
of the left I think are a far bigger
because they've taken such route with
young people I think there are a far
bigger threat to the future of this
pluralistic wonderful society that we
have than anything that I see coming out
of the right at the moment you could
actually make lots arguments that the
right has changed there's virtually no
one on the right that cares about gay
marriage anymore that's a pretty that's
a pretty significant they see the people
that write to media if you should see
them the people that write to me know
listen I mean I think that I think that
that's um was that what we we've now
gotten to the maybe biggest disagreement
that we have which is I I really believe
that that the opposite of what you just
said is true which is that these are
relatively sort of compartmentalize
problems on the left and unfortunately
we've reached the end of our time I
think the audience will not be shocked
to hear that we disagree on that but hey
okay yeah give me 30 seconds here who on
the left beside you is calling this
stuff out who is calling out this crazed
intersectional lunacy of the Dyke March
and who's calling out Linda Sarsour and
all that you know what they're not
they're actually tweeting more and more
I stand with her Bernie and Van Jones
and all of these people so who is doing
it in an effective way calling out their
worst elements I don't know I don't know
any of those people I'm like I'm in my
silo here in Boston but but think about
that and that's why I'm saying they're
being led by their worst elements
because they because people are afraid
to step up because they'll be called
racist and bigoted and all that others
so that's the part that it that's why I
believe that it is so corrosive and it
is silencing people in a really
dangerous way Dave Rubin host of the
political talk show the Rubin report I
don't know whether we've solved any
problems during this conversation but
it's been fascinating
and I think that just having it is
something that hopefully my audience
will enjoy Dave thanks for taking close
to an hour of your time to talk to me
today
my pleasure pac-man let's do it again